you're watching film courage yeah hello
everyone this is karen warning from
filters the radio show we are at VidCon
2010 we have met this wonderful young
man Jumoke ok hey guys doing very cool
gotcha monkey you have your own YouTube
bollocks I do i do my channel is a
jamocha TV j um okay II TV and right now
I write original song about my day and
things like that I lost over 100 pounds
on youtube so i was writing something on
my weight loss and michael buckley
featured me and I've been around and you
mentioned that you were also on American
Idol I was a little ear canal season 5
i'm out of two rounds and then finally
like um just okay to know and the
grinding when i get on the doggone no
nose in and so you begin your YouTube
channel win
yeah I joined it a couple years ago I
was I wasn't singing on them really i
was making like weight loss blogs and I
was like I want to incorporate my music
a little bit more and more and more
nights kept doing it and after five or
four failed attempts become partner a
male partner how do you build your
audience what are some of the tips that
you use just getting involved with
social networking and being in contact I
get really involved I reply to as many
comments as possible I talk to everybody
I have fun with it um you know just I
spent a lot of time on you to build so
if some people think they just make a
video and I spend a lot of time watching
people's videos commenting these videos
and just i love i love you too so I like
the idea that you could be anybody who
can make it just anybody
and are you sorry i'm on twitter okay
same is my youtube Jumoke TV thank you
very much thank you
you